um
so we'll start off i guess uh today
we'll be
announcing that
assuming everything stays on course uh
effective march 21st
all remaining covet uh restrictions in
nova scotia will be gone effective march
21st so
this is significant
and
i know as much as this is the news so
many have been waiting for
there are many many others who will be
extremely nervous by that news but no
matter the emotions you are experiencing
right now
we can all agree this has been a long
long run
over the last two years we've been
through an unimaginable journey as a
province as nova scotians we've seen
tragedies that are
unparalleled we've experienced all the
ups and downs of of covet itself we've
mourned together for those who have lost
loved ones
we celebrated together when the virus
eased and restrictions allowed
we delayed weddings funerals birthdays
and and delayed hugs uh we haven't seen
our grandchildren
but we did
come out in incredible numbers uh to
support our families uh friends
neighbors and and really our entire
province by getting vaccinated normally
you know at this point uh i would be
talking about case counts
and and hospitalizations in my in my
remarks but today today is different and
that's because
you know
we know that covet zero is it's not a
reality uh certainly not right now
someday hopefully maybe it will be but
it's not right now
living with covet
that's the reality that that has to
become our new reality
and i know uh and i respect
that that is a scary thought for for
some nova scotians uh
many people have felt uh protected by
the restrictions and they've seen the
restrictions as the sense of security
that they are and that they were meant
to be i understand that and uh certainly
as i say this
i'm thinking my own mom
who has been very nervous to leave the
house for two years
for others i know on the other side
there's it feels like we've uh we've had
restraints
on them that have stopped them from
being able to really live their lives
and they've missed their children's uh
sports and dance recitals and
and uh i i to them to you i know you
want your your your life back to normal
so
today uh you should see this as is the
announcing of a return to normalcy uh
even before march 7th we will see the
removal of the proof of vaccine
the proof of vaccine will be eliminated
on monday march 28th
the proof of vaccine has served its
purpose it has it has served nova
scotians well
but it was only ever meant as a
temporary measure and its time has come
we collectively know more about covet
individually we know more about coving
there is less uncertainty now
vaccination rates are high access to
vaccines is not an issue we can wear our
masks if we choose we can keep our
distance if we choose
we've had time to understand the social
impacts
and now people have the tools that they
can use to protect themselves and we are
at a point where where we
have to have confidence in nova
scotian's ability to use the tools
available to them without the government
telling them that they have to it's time